el gobierno francés busca reforzar las
medidas para frenar esta brutal segunda
ola de la epidemia de coronavirus que
está aquejando al país
emanuel mccomb convocó a un consejo de
defensa este martes para estudiar nuevas
medidas y nuevas opciones para poder
frenar esta epidemia ya la semana pasada
ron castex el primer ministro había
dicho que noviembre sería un mes
bastante difícil en la baraja pues de
estas opciones por una parte es
adelantar la hora de la toque de queda
que ya no comenzaría a las nueve de la
noche sino a las siete de la noche y que
esta vez sería para todo el territorio
nacional y otra opción es la de un
confinamiento general pero que sería
menos estricto que el del mes de marzo
algo que el gobierno pues hasta ahora
había eludido de hecho pues este martes
son castex el primer ministro tuvo dos
reuniones una con los diferentes líderes
políticos y otro con los sindicatos en
los que pues ahí les dio a conocer las
medidas que están estudiando y también
pues para lograr un consenso este
miércoles habrá un nuevo consejo de
defensa justo antes de
de la reunión del gabinete que se lleva
a cabo cada semana y será allí donde el
ejecutivo pues tome ya las decisiones
necesarias para lograr frenar esta
epidemia y de hecho se estudia que sea
el mismo presidente de manuel ma con
quien dé a conocer estos anuncios en la
noche de este miércoles